we've seen the mood in new york we've
seen the moon in washington dc what
about
uh in georgia where last time i looked
in
in the count still underway mr biden was
narrowly ahead
but it was extremely close alex crawford
now joins us from
atlanta alex
hi good afternoon adam very noisy here
because what was a gathering of people
who are going to emphasize how every
vote needs to be counted and how
um black and people of color need to be
more empowered in particularly this
state it's turned into a kind of victory
celebration
gathering a lot of these people
have spent the past few years making
sure that their vote
has counted but getting people out to
vote
in this very very close contest here
which is still too close to paul one of
the people
who's instrumental behind that is this
woman
tony watkins who's been running an
organization one of the projects who's
trying to get
the black vote out and and everyone out
voting
how do you feel first of all tony yeah
at new jersey
project in the new york new georgia
project action fund we're so excited i
can't even get it out
um we have worked so hard for so many
years
and we have flipped this we flipped the
presidency
we know that we can flip this in it and
we have so much work to do so we're
excited
but we're energized for the next eight
weeks because we know
it's gonna be crazy and we're here for
it
it's still very close to call here in
georgia how do you feel
about that i mean they still although
joe biden presidential
um democrats are ahead it's still too
close
i can tell you in georgia we feel
responsible for this
we feel like we made the difference
because whether they say that it's too
close to call or not we know that the
margin of error
we've passed it where we are past that
point so you can do the recount it
doesn't matter
the numbers that we have they are what
they are joe biden won in georgia
we flipped the state blue we changed
history and now we're going to change
the
history of the country it's quite a
dramatic turnaround isn't it after
28 years of this being a republican
stronghold what did it
what happened what was the change do you
think so
it looks like it happened overnight but
we have been out here doing this work
for four
six eight twelve years we have put in
the hours we've knocked on doors
but i think between covid and seeing the
world erupt over being tired of black
people dying
we knew that we had to come up and show
out and that's what we did so black
people have been voting
but we didn't we did show up in in
record numbers and so did everybody else
because we are different we are changing
as a people in a culture and it's time
that our government represents that
there was lots of claims of voter
suppression particularly
do you think that was that was a thing
oh yes
we had to fight with polls being closed
the day of
uh we're fighting with machines that are
not working
with voting precincts that don't have
power outlets
you cannot tell us in georgia that voter
suppression was not a thing
but we knew that it was coming we
prepared for it and we showed out anyway
tony watkins thank you very much we'll
talk to you later on in the day
come this way i want to talk to a few
other people because
the park is filling with more and more
people
um let's see what some of the the others
think about it hi guys
from british television sky sky news uk
you're on live now
how do you feel about the um the
declaration the result president-elect
joe biden
we are grateful we are happy about
everything
and uh we thank the creator for
everything
like this is this was a long-awaited day
and uh i think we're just overwhelmed
overwhelmed yeah yes it's been four days
in the counting
georgia still too close to call what was
the voting like
for you guys how did you find it when
you were casting your ballot i did early
voting and it was
easy so i'm really grateful we had a
long early voting period
i saw lots of lines though when i was
watching the voting 11 hours three hours
two hours what did you make of all of
that
i i don't i didn't have that experience
i didn't go on the first day
so yeah that's i can't comment because i
didn't see it how much my turnaround is
it
here in georgia do you think for voting
the the fact that it's so close after 28
years it's
virtually on the cusp of being well we
haven't flipped yet so i'm cautiously
optimistic and we have a huge two
run-ups coming
so i was telling her i have so much work
to do that i'm i'm having trouble
feeling excited but i am
cautiously optimistic and how about the
way
the president has behaved up until now
oh yeah terrifying i mean such a good
reason to vote the way i did
so i yeah i really feel that today is a
wonderful day but also we have
a lot to a lot of work to do about for
the next three months yeah
thank you for talking to us i don't know
whether you're still in the market of
hearing any more people we can
try and talk to some of the young people
who've been the ones who are
instrumental in
switching the vote let's have a chat to
these these guys here
hi there sorry to barge in on you from
british television sky news uk we're on
live
tell me um how how much of a dramatic
change has it been in georgia after 28
years on the cusp of
of changing to a democrat joe biden now
president-elect how are you feeling i
mean i feel great i feel like this has
been decades in the making stacey abrams
is the one to credit she's done so much
work
stacy abrams is the person who ran in
2018 for governor and lost out very
closely
very very closely and i don't know if
she actually truly lost i think the
election was a little bit stolen
it's relatively mainstream you know
opinion
but uh we're all so happy this is it's
about time you know and the south is
where
there's so much power uh towards
changing the vote and there's
it's just incredible so everyone's very
happy
there's a few trump supporters outside
state farm arena
who are still declaring that the the the
vote has been stolen that the election
has been stolen
i just you know every four years the
president is voted out and a new
president comes in
and so this is no different and the
people have spoken and
unfortunately it's a little closer than
we'd all like but
the people have spoken and it's a normal
thing that happens every four years so
i'm not sure why they think that this
shouldn't happen
right